- You guys just look like
you're having so much fun
in your engagement.
Are you guys enjoying it as much
as we feel it and see it?
- Yes.
- Yeah, we are.
- And we're so thrilled to
be on the cover of The Knot.
And talking about it here on
your show, Drew, our show,
because it's important to us
to share our love
with the world.
- Yeah.
And we made a conscious decision
to do that because why?
- [Wellinthon] Well, because
growing up an immigrant
from Dominican Republic and
him being a little farm boy
from Mount Vernon we never saw that.
And it's important to actually
have that representation
out there and just value that anyone
can actually have that
as well, so excited.
- Yeah.
- Growing up, think about that.
We didn't even know.
We didn't even dream
about getting married one day.
- No.
Because it wasn't even an option for us.
And so we think by sharing our love story
and showing it to everyone
maybe there's a little kid out there
who can look at us and go,
"Oh my God, I deserve that.
I deserve love."